an dieser stelle natürlich herzlichen
glückwunsch schon mir generell an alle
die irgendwie aber jetzt haben oder
irgendeinen abschluss geschafft haben
alles gute viel glück im weiteren
verlauf im neuen leben trotzdem muss ich
würde 100 euro drauf wetten du hast in
martina 1 wenn ich komm vorbei kannst
dir 100 euro abholen passt perfekt
leute was geht ab von willkommen bei
einem neuen video irgendwie ist das doch
ein bisschen zu tief
das macht ja weil ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut von mir kamen ungefähr vor
eineinhalb wochen oder zwei wochen das
video
wir erwarten euren zeugnis durchschnitt
aber ich glaube das ist so ein
mittelding 2,5 sag ich was soll 3,4
durch ja ist echt gut angekommen und wir
haben sehr viele leute gesagt alex macht
doch mal bitte im zweiten teil
und ich habe mir gedacht warum
eigentlich nicht ich habe ja auch gesagt
ihr könnt ihr über instagram euer
zeugnis zu schicken den bild von euch zu
schicken mit eurem zeugnis schnitt meine
aufgabe ist es halt den schnitt zu
erraten anhand eines fotos natürlich
kann man das ganze mal ein bisschen
oberflächlich sehen ich meine ihr habt
mir ganz viele fotos geschickt ich
schaue mir die an und tippe darauf okay
die person passt in der schule auf oder
die person gibt vielleicht so einen
kleinen auf die schule da ich bin
spontan auf die idee gekommen ich will
natürlich niemanden angreifen oder
sonstwas und ich halte mich da auch ein
bisschen zurück falls man das so sagen
kann ist ja auch an sich ähnlich wie
alte erraten nur halt mit zeugnis
durchschnitt ich will gar nicht
eingeladen für noch ein paar fast 8000
leichter und wir fangen an mit dem
ersten foto und das ist dieses hier muss
man ein bisschen über rutschen ich habe
glaube ich insgesamt so 10 rausgesucht
ich sag mal wenn ich vier davon
annähernd richtig einschätze das heißt
immer mit 0,3 nach oben und nach unten
ist okay das heißt wenn ich bei dieser
person jetzt sage boah das können wir so
ein lockeres 1,8 sein und die person
aber 2,1 oder 1,5 kriegt trotzdem punkt
okay das ist ein bisschen zu leicht wir
sagen einfach mal 0,2 das heißt wenn sie
als 2,0 oder 1,6 und ich sage 18 kriege
ich trotzdem punkt also ich habe 1,8
gesagt und auf ihrem t-shirt steht jetzt
das heißt 18 ist vermutlich nicht
richtig will der achten klasse auf dem
gymnasium hab es jetzt so ein schnitt
von 2,31 aber wir bekommen noch noten
das ist jetzt aber ein bisschen komisch
ich meine du sagst hat es jetzt so den
schnitt von 2,31 würdest du jetzt sagen
habe ist jetzt ungefähr so im schnitt
zwischen 2 und 2,5 kann ich ja verstehen
aber du hast einfach genau so auf den
punkt 2,31 raus ob die noten hat war
doch gar nicht na ja gut ich glaube wir
jetzt mal ich lag falsch
soviel schöne grüße wir machen weiter
mit der nächsten person und haben hier
den namen weil ich halt leider nicht
okay also der erste punkt ging schon mal
nicht an mich diesmal sage ich 'ihr
könnt natürlich auch immer vielleicht in
den kommentaren mit raten schwierig
schwierig 2,6 2,6 sag ich und 1,9 abitur
sogar schon sondern eben war wohl nix
auch hier schnitzel 14
schöne grüße danke für deine einsendung
und wir machen sofort weiter mit diesem
der hier haben wir den sts keine ahnung
gute brille und das wäre jetzt ein fall
für mich dann würde ich mal darauf
tippen so der sieht so ein bisschen
lässt sich aus vielleicht wieder die
schule gehabt nicht kannst du ernst
genommen deswegen würde ich jetzt
einfach mal so sagen 3,0 und co
alter es ist wirklich 3,0 für die sich
jetzt vielleicht fragen alex du musst
dir doch irgendwie diese sachen selber
aussuchen du siehst das davor schon
allein bei solchen erraten videos macht
es meistens mein mitbewohner für mich
versucht das dann raus und schickt mir
das also nur damit ihr mitleid will ist
also ein punkt geht schon mal auf mein
konto wir machen weiter mit dieser
jungen dame ja da bin ich mir eigentlich
sicher das ist eine ganz locker lässige
1,3 2,3 hatte ich auch in meinem abitur
also irgendwie ist bis jetzt noch nicht
so wirklich das glück auf meiner seite
wir lassen das erst mal so stehen und
kommen zu ganz stark ich habe euch das
gesagt leute schickt mir bitte einmal
euer bild und dann separat euren zeigt
dass durchschnitt und aaron sagt sich
gut machen wir einfach mal beides in
einem
3,9 also wenn ich mir den aaron so
angucke da würde ich eigentlich direkt
auf 3,9 tippen und das ist drei mal neun
ja- und danke für deine einsendung
leider hast du glaub ich den sinn vom
video nicht ganz verstanden
trotzdem natürlich schöne grüße komme
ich zur nächsten person ich habe mir ich
versucht mich wahrscheinlich mit ein
wenig erotischen reizen zu einer
besseren einschätzung zu verleiten kann
ich aber in diesem fall sagen ich bin
nicht so wie diese ganzen ekligen
männlichen lehrer bei mir zieht das
nicht ich tippe auf man das ist so
schwer ich tippe auf 2,2 und es ist 1,7
ich wollte 1,27 sagen na ja schon wieder
falsch ich glaube von fünf verschiedenen
personen habe ich bis jetzt ein punkt da
ist auf jeden fall noch luft nach oben
aber marie cutie danke für deine einzel
und so kommen wir zum nächsten bild und
hier freut sich jemand extrem ja ich
habe mein zeugnis bekommen und wenn man
sich schon so darüber freut dann muss
das ja auch wirklich etwas gutes sein
deswegen würde ich jetzt einfach mal
sagen pass auf das ist sicherlich zum
schüler 13 schnitt 2,6 7
also sharleena
ich war zwar auch nicht besser aber ich
habe mich auch nicht so gefreut
nein spaß also 2,6 ist vollkommen okay
wollen sie hat vermutlich hier mit ihren
abschluss geschafft oder so an dieser
stelle natürlich herzlichen glückwunsch
von mir generell an alle die irgendwie
aber jetzt haben oder irgendein
abschluss geschafft haben alles gute
viel glück im weiteren verlauf von neuen
leben kommen sie mal guten teuren ziel
an
und wieso habe ich hier jetzt so einen
roten kratzer hat sich den gerade auch
schon gut willkommen zum nächsten bild
die person ist man wirklich schon etwas
älter wir haben ihre tattoos oft in den
fingern und auf dem arm das heißt es
handelt sich vermutlich um abitur oder
fachabi an der berufsschule keine ahnung
da fällt mir eigentlich sofort 2,2 ein
und es ist kann man zwar schon ein stück
her aber abschluss mit 3,2 warte mal von
sieben personen habe ich einfach nur
eine richtig ich dachte eigentlich
manche der sonne gute kenntnis für sowas
generell alter erwarten namen erraten
größte erraten
naja gut kommen wir zu mischen auch hier
ist ja justus und hier muss ich sagen
justus sieht extrem schlau aus vor allem
so ich glaube jetzt das ist so ein
richtiger mathematiker oder physiker
eins von beiden
und wenn ich jetzt mit meiner 1,3
daneben liege dann weiß ich auch nicht
mehr also justus 1 43 sage ich 1,9 ist
zu spät oder was ist zu spät gut ich lag
wieder daneben das kennen wir ja
mittlerweile schon
trotzdem muss ich würde 100 euro drauf
wetten du hast in matten a1 wenn ich
komm vorbei kannst dir 100 euro abholen
kommen wir zum nächsten bild irgendwie
sehen die schon älter aus oder ich muss
jetzt zu sagen ich habe keinen plan um
welche person es geht irgendwie sind ja
auch komplett gleich aus vielleicht sind
es ja zwillinge die auch den gleichen
zeugnis durchschnitt haben auch hier
ich habe keine ahnung sagen wir einfach
mal 1,9 das ist
1,9 und wir haben hier ja 2,4 schon
wieder falsch alles falsch ich habe
keinen bock mehr
letztes mal war ich echt besser glaube
ich so ein paar aber noch das ist der
weiß ich nicht aber coole schuhe auch
sehr schwierig da ich immer komplett
falsch lag würde ich hier einfach mal
sagen 2,7 4,0 durchschnitt hatten wenig
letzten mal auch schon eine durchschnitt
falsch geschrieben hat was soll 3,4
durch ja also bei euch kann ich dann
leider nur sagen oder vielleicht kommt
ja aus österreich und da schreibt man
das so kann google übersetzer irgendwie
nicht österreichische übersetzen
vielleicht war es auch die autokorrektur
keine ahnung aber man schreibt
durchschnitt nicht so wie du geschrieben
hast
eigentlich habe ich ein auto korrektur
also kein problem
nächstes schuljahr wird es bestimmt ich
weiß nicht nur 35 ich drücke die daumen
schöne grüße auch hier und wir machen
weiter mit
wo bist du dann reingefallen
na gut ich sagt 2,6 und wir haben gibt
es ja gar nicht
zweiter punkt auf mein konto 2,8 und
eine person haben wir noch wir haben
hier die das hier hatte ich ziemlich
schaue zwar ich weiß es nicht aber hier
sage ich 167 hat 18 noch ein punkt also
ich glaube ich habe also von elf oder
zwölf leuten drei richtig ist auf jeden
fall noch ausbaufähig trotzdem ist es
immer wieder interessant ja also schickt
mir gerne weiteres zu wie schon am
anfang gesagt wenn der bock habt dass
ich noch ein paar mache dann mal wieder
mit irgendwem anders in der challenge
oder so klassen nach oben da jackpot und
instagram ab vor allem instagram und für
mich geht es jetzt heute nacht in den
urlaub wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich
freitag wieder und auch ganz wichtig
weil ich ja jetzt in den urlaub fahre es
gibt bei den reise kanal von mir der ist
auch mal ganz oben wie die beschreibung
verlinkt falls sie dennoch nicht
abonniert haben geht auf jeden fall mal
rauslassen schönes aber da sind schon
drei videos online da kommt auch
ungefähr in zwei wochen ein neues video
online
deswegen wird sich mega mega freuen bei
den kanal abonnieren da kommt für mich
immer nur so
projekte online wo man halt sagen kann
ok da steckt so wirklich voll
leidenschaft und spaß drin natürlich
machen wir diese videos hier auch spaß
aber die videos die ich dafür schneider
so reisevideos das machen wir halt noch
mal mehr spaß deswegen wirklich mega
freuen abonnieren schaut euch die videos
dann weißt du noch nicht getan habt und
janáceks snapshot und instagram ab wir
sehen uns freitag wieder habe ich glaube
ja schon gesagt haut rein leute zschau